hello there as i understand it a
standalone
season we'll see who knows i've been
dreaming of doing a trip through south
america for years
we'll ride 13 000 miles from the
southern tip of argentina
all the way to los angeles this is your
third rendition
of the long way tour but it's been i
think 13 years since your last trip
and you two lost touch and then charlie
had an accident so walk me through like
what happened how did you guys reconnect
and how did you decide to take another
trip we didn't lose touch as much as we
just didn't see much of each other i
moved to the states
charlie was in in london and um
it just we just got busy our lives had
sort of
uh my i was involved in all my acting
work and charlie's
um was doing lots of motorcycle tours
and
um making other television shows sorry
that's my
little dog i mean it's a big button
um and one way or another we'd sort of
just drifted apart a little bit
and then charlie unfortunately had a
terrible motorcycle accident
in them portugal where he got extremely
injured
and and in a way that sort of um
please bro she's still now we have to
see him now we have to see it
she's just walking around so hacking up
oh
wow so excited
you know you was often coming over to
london and making it uh
making a movie but i was away doing
other tv shows and so we never got
together and then so i'm
stuck here and then euron was making a
film here and he came over to
stay for a few days and ended up staying
for about a month and
and we had such a lovely time again
together you know it's
when when great best friends kind of
meet up again and you haven't seen each
other for a while just
kind of pick up from where you left off
you know and um
and we were starting to talk about the
tv show and we started talking about
just
old tv shows and what we've done and we
still we're thinking about long way up
you and
really really wanted to do south america
and central america and
we started talking about it and then
russ and dave who are our business
partners
uh and that's my job to come
don't come and say hello now yeah
and uh i'm so sorry and
then we kind of rust and did come over
for for a barbecue in our
in our garden and we sort of said look i
think we really want to do a long way up
and
and then we start talking about you know
because the world has changed we started
talking about electric and
and then before you know we go yeah
we'll just we'll do electric bikes no
problem at all
it's something like that you're in
something like that i mean the truth of
it is
is when when somebody that you love has
gone through
an accident like that and when we all
found out about charlie's accident
there's that there's that period of time
when you don't know
quite what's going to happen and there
was i think all of us were worried that
charlie
that that uh what were you first of all
you worry about the worst and then you
you hear that it just shocks you into
remembering that there are people in
your life that are very important and
that
you have to remind yourself to just keep
that friendship alive and i think
you know we both experienced something
by doing our two other trips long way
around and long way down
together that that that makes our
rel our friendship unique in our lives
like i i don't
have a relationship with anyone else in
the world like i have for charlie
because
i went through those journeys riding
behind him
in front of him or next to him you know
we've done that together so
it's sort of a unique bond and um it
just sort of
woke up me up to thinking god i can't
let that can't let that slip you know
and then and then and then it led us to
do this trip which is great
you guys did this trip with electric
bikes versus like being like oh man i'm
kind of getting low on gas i should pull
over
um what kind of challenges did having
electric bikes
present that i know you guys could like
you can only plan so much like what were
the hiccups what came up
well i suppose luckily you know um the
whole world has electric
and and and you know i think um it was a
steep learning curve for us i i don't
think we quite
understood how electric worked and
there's all that
range anxiety syndrome that you have
when you're first going in will you make
it a bit like when people first started
driving petrol cars
you know you get the car and think oh
well will i make it and if i get there
will there be petrol
and it was the same sort of thing with
the with the electric and we would
sort of sit there in the morning and
have breakfast and we'd look at the map
and say look well we can
here let's let's play and make it from
there to there and see what happens and
and what was lovely about it is that is
that you would get to to these places in
a in a youth hostel
or a b b or or somewhere
and you say look do you mind if we plug
in and people were absolutely
handsome yeah come on in and wow what a
trip and
so suddenly you're you're not just
plugging your bike in but you're
plugging into people's lives in a very
different way
and that brought on loads of experiences
for us and
and um you know we slowly got into the
rhythm of it and
it turned out to be the right choice i
really i really think
yeah you can definitely see that you
guys you guys make a lot of connections
on this trip one of my favorite parts of
the trailer i don't know if you guys can
see what my interests are
back here but you and you say
uh you know i'm an actor and they're
like is there anything you we would
recognize you from here like star wars
it just
silence did anybody see
star wars no i don't think so
none of these kids have seen anything
got done
i mean we were in the top of this
mountain this tiny little village
in um was it peru because
yeah it was peru we're doing it and yes
it was
amazing to meet and we were we were
doing a unicef to a visit
um in a school that teaches the kids in
their indigenous language
which which had which was was something
that unicef are helping
the these um these little
some stories she's got like a hater of
her throat or something
what is it rose come here come here come
here come on look you just can't
and then and so it was it was nice to it
was nice to be up there but then
of course they're they're living a very
different life than ours
yeah and they had they had not seen any
of my movies so i left and a half i was
disgraced
i have a bad feeling about this are you
gearing up to shoot what's the deal
yeah very soon and uh the spring next
year we start so i'm really excited
about it i'm super excited about it it's
gonna be great i think gosh i can't wait
so so that's supposed to be one season
do you now that you're like
gearing up are you like maybe i would
want to do two
uh there's no talk of two i mean there's
a it's a pretty much
as i as i understand it a stand-alone
season we'll see who knows i'm jazzed
about that well you guys had said that
you saw this
journey as a three-parter but now that
it's all said and done are you kind of
like
uh maybe we would do another one maybe
we want to go on another journey
you know it's funny because we whenever
you ever on the last two that we that we
did we
just as we're coming to finish one we'd
always talk about another one in order
to make it easy
to finish that one thinking you know
we've got one in the bag
so i think you know you and i certainly
did talk about
lots of possible adventures so i mean
you never know
i think you know this might be a couple
in us yet you never know yeah yeah
yeah there's life in the old dogs yet
charlie yeah
long way across there's many more
directions to go
and then we might have to just rethink
the title i mean the only reason we
started this trip in usual in the south
as opposed to
prepping the trip in la and riding south
which you know
the majority of people who leave from
america would do
it was because of the name of trip it
we'd already done long way around we've
done a long way down so we had to do
long way up you had to go up
so we had to prep the trip and then ship
everything there it made it very
complicated
but just so that we could have the title
of the show we had to do it
that's great i love it ones we could
always do
you know there's always long long way
down under you know
longer yeah long way scandinavia
always scanty uh well thank you guys so
much i am out of time but it was such a
pleasure to talk to you guys
thank you to see you lovely to be here
[Music]
bye
you